but i love that you tell that story and
then how incredible you think that that
boy that kid who did that you know with
his money
uh just a couple of months ago there you
were wembley stadium
uh 90 000 people broke skybox office
records
showed 140 countries world heavyweight
champion beating vladimir klitschko i
mean it's an incredible incredible
achievement i mean very good
the thing that fascinates you i think
we've got a still of when he when you
slipped
um you can see the position i mean
yeah i mean look there obviously some
water there
but when when that happens and you find
yourself on the canvas
and that's in the sixth round you've
been boxing for a while like yeah
where do you go to in your head to kind
of because it must be so hard not to
think
this is over you can think that it's
like
this is the one thing i didn't train for
out of all the stuff i've been training
for this is the one thing that you don't
prepare for so
you go into that fight or flight mode
where it's like okay i could either stay
on my back and say to myself
i've given it my all and i'm happy with
coming this far or you go up and fight
the extra rounds and you think
i want to go that little bit further
it's just that fight or flight mode
because as i said it's not something
that you prepare for yeah so when you
find
yourself in that situation i think then
it becomes about character
so who are you take away all the stuff
that you've been taught
you have to unteach yourself and go into
who are you what do you represent and
that's a fight i'm i'm a fighting man so
i got up and just
carried on scrapping with him and the
11th round you knock him down you get
the title
in the end was that stamina was that
just you being a much younger man he's
41.
i don't know you know he was he come in
unbelievable shape
he was he's phenomenally experienced and
i just think as i said because he was
knocked down
i was knocked down we were both tired i
think it was just about character and i
think
it's that spike you need a bit you need
that spike you know i mean you need that
you know it's like them horses like no
one put that vix on my nose that fight
that's basically the best
[Music]
you